[Music]
[Applause]
boom what's up everyone welcome to
simulation I'm your host Don shotgun
super excited to be talking about
thriving futures to be talking about
creating a world that works for all
beings in the shortest amount of time we
have Maya sacrum and joining us on the
show hello hello how are you thank you
so much for coming for having me here
decided yes we are very grateful for
your work and for your passion which are
bringing to our world and for those that
don't know Maya's background
regenerative entrepreneur futurist
the CEO of veem which is a next-gen
social video network and we're gonna be
talking about that I love that about
creating the world that works for all
beings in the shortest amount of time
that is so beautifully said it's kind of
like the pinnacle goal of civilization
and so okay we like talking about things
on a big history perspective to start so
here we find ourselves as stewards of
Earth after period of evolution and boom
what is your current synthesis on the
state of humanity so you use the word
stewards we're not there yet where I
feel we're still in the adolescent stage
I mean what are the lessons clean up the
room
none look at the state of the world
we're in this kind of some of us a
preteen queen maybe and all of a sudden
we're got all this power and we're
actually haven't adult is enough to get
to this point I mean it's funny that 30s
and 40s the word adulting we know
there's a problem when bats are in our
framework so you know we have this
amazing Goldilocks planet I mean we go
out to the other other universe to
actually look for Goldilocks places
sorry other galaxies to look for
Goldilocks planets and we're standing on
a Goldilocks planet and we forgot that I
really truly believe that we forgot this
ya know we've been using the words
ethical kindergarten this kind of story
the stewardship is kind of like a slow
process of getting to become more kind
of like grandparents if the proper was
wise stewards of earth it's taking us a
little longer to get there maybe it is
even possible that the civilizations
prior to us had greater spiritual wisdom
to their connectedness to Mother Earth
and then it's kind of been lost yeah
through this massive population and
exponential technology boom would you
say that yeah I mean there's there's
been a few I mean no wonder we're using
frames like falling from grace and and
and have this nostalgic memory for
places that were before civilization
that was our paradise fall from grace
was moving from from this
hunter-gatherer communities into
civilization and there was a fall that
was literally a break and we've also
systematically actually dislocated we
know we've killed off people we've you
know indigenous people indigenous tribes
around the world have been suffering for
five hundred years from colonialism even
before that for the past ten thousand
years though I believe we made a
decision that some people are better
than others and we've actually encoded
that into our narrative you see it in
judeo-christian narratives of the hero's
journey even though not that hero's
journey is just a very slim part of the
real narrative that's been there and you
see it also in how we've actually
removed ourselves from others from our
tribes from people from nature from one
another we forgot that we belong to each
other we belong to the planet that we're
not actually a hundred percent human
we're like ten percent and the rest of
it is microbiome and connectedness
through all these kind of organisms that
are making these communities so we
actually created a very myopic narrative
of our place in the world and we've done
it systematically and all of a sudden
we're in this moment right now where
we're remembering the past and the
future together like we're actually have
a memory of the paths of future of what
we could be and
memory of the past where we're still
aching and and no wonder we're seeing
huge amounts of indigenous leaders
around the world stepping up to remind
us of the past so we can remember the
future together yeah that's so well said
there's you were mentioning earlier to
the notion that this is such a gorgeous
planet that we have as our home and it's
because we find ourselves in this
gorgeous Goldilocks zone this perfect
distance from the star that made life
happen for us
and just the gratitude as we look at
Venus and Mars and we're just like wow
how lucky is it that we are right here
and just that sense of gratitude and
then following up on your point here you
know we just had a friend Stephanie in
and she was teaching us about what was
happening down in South America with
some of the Amazonian indigenous people
and it is it's so unfortunate like
you've been describing now it's been
this this trajectory of colonialism this
superiority complex that we have that we
are we're we're suffering because of our
deep ego and our deep greed and our deep
dehumanization of other people for
economic superiority and gains that end
up being meaningless when we go and we
aim to get these materialistic
possessions these extra things outside
that don't actually bring any
fulfillment or meaning to our lives the
deep human connections and actually
seeing a flourishing world break it
brings that to us now you know you you
you bring up the indigenous people and
you bring up being able to learn from
them and integrate their this holistic
sense of communion with nature with
earth back into our value system to move
forward yeah just about that yeah so I
mean everything we can learn from the
planet I mean we've created amazing
things by observing and then all of a
sudden something happened and we just
went exponential the thing is we can
grow continually growing exponentially
because nothing on the planet does that
like things actually are in balance so I
think the first thing is let's look back
into biomimicry and look at what the
planet
to regenerate itself to actually create
an equilibrium to actually have
flourishing and thriving ecosystems and
if we look at our cities I mean
everything came out from our own stories
right like even this mud here is a story
right if somebody had an idea of how to
hold how to hold like our ancestors how
do I hold liquid how do I hold warm
liquid and all of a sudden we have mugs
of all shapes and sizes and you know
memes on them and all of a sudden there
a cultural refract you know reflection
of who we are
just the smug right times all of us so
we've always you know been very great at
storytelling as an animal and but we've
actually forgot to tell the story of the
planet like we deem that not as
important versus our own these stories I
think one of the things is honouring the
planet and then reflecting back to what
she wants to teach us I'm very much
about the mother earth use and and she's
trying to tell us something you know one
of the things that she's trying to tell
us pretty much in our faces and we're
still wondering wait what is she's
trying to say here and I'm gonna I'm
gonna say a feminist joke it's the guy's
not listening to the woman again like
come on she's creaming at you
we're behaving like viruses we're just
exploding everywhere and when we have a
viral infection in our body the first
thing that happens is we get a fever
it's exactly what's happening to the
planet it's getting a fever so if she
can actually deal with us as we've
changed our narrative we've changed our
behavior from being a species that's
part of the equilibrium to something
that's out of nature reflecting back and
I don't think that we're gonna be
allowed to stay here for this much
longer and I don't think we're gonna be
allowed to actually go on another planet
I think we're kind of in this in-between
land until we grow up and actually learn
from the thriving systems the ecosystems
that are here they're they're amazing
this is 4.4 billion years of brilliance
you know we think we know it all oh my
god no we we don't know how to create us
like she's great us us that's that's
that's evolution for you and that's so
much information
we're only
raping it so and I think humility and
and Carl Sagan and Neil deGrasse Tyson
talk about the cosmic perspective so the
cosmic perspective is when you actually
gain that perspective of the cosmos
looking back here and you know we only
gain that through science I mean that's
something I'm very much about the
scientist a scientific method but when
we bring back the humanity when we bring
back the AH the cultivation of awe and
astronomy is like that right we only
gained the awe of our of us as part of
this planetary system after 1968 and 69
and 72 you know the the first satellite
that brought in the Whole Earth Catalog
so satellite image of Earth and then
Earth rising 69 and in 72 is a blue
marble so literally within three years
of four years we gain what it looks what
we look like from the outside that's
only been about 51 years that's crazy
we've only actually had acknowledged we
are should not be expected to be that
adult because we've only learned that
we're really part of this ecosystem so
we need more time to mature and maybe
hit the brakes a little bit unlike the
Exponential's because we need it's this
you know like I run startups any startup
knows that there is a place between the
time you run out of gas and you actually
get your product to market and in that
time you're gonna die so we're literally
in that time between we're gonna run out
of gas for this for this planet to
actually sustain us and before we
actually learn how to truly evolve as a
species and we've got a window that's
like 11 years maybe then it's closing
and it really is about all of us all
hands on deck waking up and going and
waking up growing up cleaning up and
showing up because waking up is not
enough anymore and we can talk about it
a little bit I love
yeah Wow yeah your synthesis on things
is really powerful yeah that's really
strong and you bring a lot of I love how
you bring the cosmic perspective I love
how you bring the indigenous wisdom
perspective I love how you bring the the
even the economic and political flows
today and how we need to fix some of the
roots of these issues and upgrade to the
2.0 systems I am loving it I'm loving it
yeah of course the the the cosmic
perspective is a huge aspect to our
awakening like here's our little blue
marble where we've all lived and died
hundred billion of us that built
civilization and now we see of course
some of the things that we do on this
rock are acting as a you know the way
you describe it it's hard for us to
admit that in some ways we are being a
little viral we are being a little
parasitic and you know someone may even
argue and say it's completely parasitic
and and it's really hard for humans to
to feel that in their bodies that you
know we are throwing things out of
equilibrium and that the fever is is
here now and the fever is like you know
what are we gonna do to fix this
equilibrium and so that's happening and
you also you also gave this this super
cool wise man or wise woman sees a
different tree yeah or in this case a
mug yeah
then a fool that is a man or a woman
because when you look at it you can just
say that there it is or you can have the
full perspective of the thousands of
years of humans realizing that they
wanted to keep water in these mug shaped
bowl shaped contraptions and so so just
like with the tree system you can see
the roots and you can see the leaves the
animals and they're the sunlight that's
that's that's that that goes in the
photosynthesis that occurs everything
fact so I'm I'm really loving the
okay now given you were and you ended on
these steps right yeah go ahead and
teach us about those steps
so not mine I I always bring in awesome
people's words so the integral thoughts
ken wilber and and and the other
integrals talk about an awesome formula
and I mean we've got a little Buddha
here
awesome formulas are not an invention of
the 2021 21st century
he gave us like a bunch of them like
three pearls for Four Noble Truths
Eightfold Path really succinct good very
very simple right so that's what's
getting back into the simplicity from
the complexity so they talk about waking
up growing up cleaning up and showing up
so I talk I have a article I talk about
waking up because everybody's like oh we
gotta wake up and I think the only
people who get really what waking up is
is black lives matter uses the concept
of stay woke which means o waking up is
an actually practice staying woke as a
practice this is not like oh I wake up
and oh and everything's okay so here's
I'm gonna take me about even deeper some
of my favorite sages are the Wachowski
siblings I used to be the with chops
which offski Brothers now there were
chaski sisters amazing yeah mind blown
right so the matrix you remember the
major for sure so what happens to neo
wench and he wakes up he wakes up in a
pod and he literally has a purging
moment if from a lot of from a lot of
spiritual narratives and spiritual
ceremonies the concept of purge
literally goes like a bullet and then
things dislocate from him and then he
gets washed down the drain into the
sewage so it sucks and he wakes up to
seeing darkness all around them and
people are enslaved and then the
Nebuchadnezzar and Morpheus pick him up
with the robotic arms and they they dry
him up and then he's still I blurry eyes
blurry
he asked Morpheus why don't my eyes work
and he says because you've never used
them so that's waking up and I think
everybody's kind of stuck on this it's
like no that's right
like we're kind of stuck in like thee Oh
waking up to so wonderful nice X cuz you
wake up to reality and you're like [ __ ]
how do I deal with this now
and then the growing up is maturity is
you know part of a step that we need to
take is grieving and as a Western
society we don't know how to grieve with
no idea what to do with friends of ours
that are losing it they're like oh we're
good we're like oh it's not that bad
it's gonna be okay and it's like no it
sucks like let's sit with us let's go
through our process by ourselves and
collectively of what we are responsible
for maybe not we created we were born
into this I'm not specifically decided
that I want to go and kill the Amazon
and rip the earth of minerals and used
by use fuels to run for planes I'm in I
was born into that situation but I'm
responsible for that
and that's a little kind of place where
it's really difficult to sit with so we
got to do that work we are responsible
for that you can't take the blame
yourself that's quite admirable yeah we
are we are responsible yeah we are
collectively responsible so I just don't
put it all on you my there's only so
much you can do right now but thanks for
being you nevertheless yeah and and it's
not an easy thing and that's why for us
to actually do the external work we all
have to go and do our shadow works it's
kind of funny where the shadow always
has company on this poster over there we
always have our shadows this is not new
this is 2500 years but Jesus that's
interesting yeah the the comparison to a
binary star system yeah a two star
system then you have then you have a
good and an evil yeah you have that you
have that shadow self that's with you
all the time and that way when you tap
into the current state of not evil and
it's just shadow
it's just shadows well if you one can
one can say whatever is happening with
the forces that are at play that are
pushing things in the direction of up
that are synergizing however one
describe those things but when one
awakens and then further stays awake and
this is this is what your well your what
you're teaching the the the process of
doing this is at times like your you
described it is not necessarily a
process that people think feels great
it's probably most probably all the time
kind of sucks and I use the word suck a
lot here because it's not easy and and
for us to actually get as humans even
just if let's remove the calamity we're
in and the challenges just as a human
being in this world is is hard you know
it's a society just that how do we show
up in our lives for ourselves and for
our families and community just that is
a lot of work then what is asked for us
as a society under the species is do our
internal work in our collective work at
the same time really fast it is the
question of the times I think I really
truly believe it and I see that and no
wonder all of a sudden there's this
resurgence of anything from self-help to
indigenous healing practices all around
the world for us Gringo's to come in
because we're so hurting and you can
actually hear from the indigenous
leaders what they're seeing and they're
seeing this pain this shadow this with
techo in us that has been eating us our
soul because we forgot they were
connected to the planet and it's
literally in us and we feel it we feel
it when we walk down the street we feel
you know I'm walking down the street in
San Francisco and Market Street it's
just okay yeah it is it is in some in
you know in a lot of ways it is yeah it
it's just a concrete jungle in Manhattan
there's not even any trees or sunlight
it's just 40 storey concrete buildings
and it's it's gotten and then the
lighter that again what you face I want
to get a close-up shot in that 40 storey
concrete bill
and there's no trees and there's barely
any sunlight that can come in there and
then the humans that are laying on the
streets yeah
that we walk by that we have decided
that we don't have time in our busy
lives to address this issue
yeah and then the indigenous people that
are screaming connect to earth feel your
hearts look at each other's eyes realise
the infinity that you come from and how
blessed we are to be here and solve this
problem of what's going on on the planet
before we get to points of further
catastrophe to actually get to the point
where we can leverage the beautiful
tools these a law of accelerating
returns that we have to actually do
things like like monitor our biometrics
in a preventive medicine take us into
the space economy and beyond doing all
these cool things enables us to grow up
and stay woke stay awakened for a long
long sustained period and it's it is it
is it the process feels like this
because death you gain the understanding
of the code we talk about the code a lot
and when you realize the variables
approaching eight billion of us
everyone's aiming to live like a meat
consumer a high energy fossil fuel
burner having for procreation ism is
important because it brings us meaning
adding more humans we want to burn
through our clothes and our and our
degradable so that are not that are dead
don't biodegrade of a couple of days but
they take months or even years to
biodegrade in oceans so I'm happy that
you have a very you're very Polymathic
in your understanding you hit a bunch of
edges of knowledge of the way that you
synthesize these points but the center
of it the center of it is I believe told
me if I'm where I'm if I'm right here is
this is this is this sort of like
ancient guy of this ancient
wisdom of Pachamama of Mother Earth and
what on how to best harmonize with her
as we move forward as a unity yes yeah
completely and as my dear friend Joe
Brewer says reminding ourselves what it
means to be human like literally
dropping down with each other and and
reminding ourself of a future that is is
here because we know the times are
really not linear so we've already seen
that future and it's very interesting
for me that only a few of our awesome
mainstream culture narratives are of
this positive future and you can name
them on like one hand and most of the
other ones are connected to our limbic
brain or fight and flight are the
dystopian ones and and it's a repetitive
in our not in a 20th century 21st
century narrative look at the the angel
ancient Bibles that we have the all of
the Bible's the from the Hindu to to the
Jewish and Christian ones all talk about
apocalypse all talk about that concept
but apocalypse in the ancient terms is
not the end it's an end of an epoch it's
an end of a moment and a beginning of a
new one and we're in that that's what it
feels so uncomfortable because we are
birthing something new my parent we
might birthing be birthing our end and
and if we're doing that you know that's
always something that is possible maybe
we should consider did you say birthing
the end we may and yeah hey Ron is
excited now with the thriving future
options yeah is that as well but I'm
gonna go back to the end for a second
and entertainment one of the one of my
favorite ways of a species to leave a
time is the elves in Lord of the Rings
there's an honor and and maturity about
it and going well let's actually leave
the place better than we found it before
we we make before we leave so let's
let's get on the big war to help
everybody because we're gonna stay some
of us are gonna stay to actually take
care steward the next epoch so that
could be an option and then there's a
thrival future option which is that's
the Goldilocks
a time line you know can we get to the
time line that not too hot and not too
cold you know really truly and that's
not big enough and not too small not too
technological and not to you you know
hippy 8o pian something that works for
everybody and when I say everybody I
mean everybody like the bees the whales
the the elders I was just I'm a part of
this wonderful course called speak the
spark sacred storytelling and we had
this amazing Leah lamb run facilitates
it and we had this amazing elder from
Hawaii Kalani and he asked the three
questions for our thriving society are
thee are the grandchildren fed of the
grandparents comfortable are the women
unafraid and and then we kind of
dissected each one of them fed means the
children fed it could be food it could
be education it could be a good space
for children and grandchildren the
youngest ones comfortable for
grandparents means that as they age and
they're you know they're more disabled
or or you need more help they're always
comfortable comfortable means they have
enough food a place to stay somebody to
take care of them somebody to speak to
they're not lonely and then our women
aren't afraid yeah I walked in San
Francisco I'm never feeling very
comfortable and I remember somebody even
writing work what about the men they're
like they're in the grandparents and
they're in the ground grandchildren so
men are actually in those two but I
think for women or anybody that's not in
the place of the stronger male authority
that is really important and I think
that is part of for community-based not
only for nature is how we start building
that because we need to come in from you
know before we try to fix the outside
fix the inside how are we done within
our communities yes yes that trust and
safety is so critical there's a there's
an interesting analogy for men there's
that if men
had these seven-foot alien creatures
that were down here and just constantly
wanting to [ __ ] us yeah and and doing
whatever they want to pressure us into
wanting to you know [ __ ] them
yeah and like we would have to also
really be you know how can we be safe
etc so there's ways to try and put
yourself behind the eyes of these
imaginary scenarios where you can be
like okay I get it like I don't want to
be preyed on like that like let's find a
better communion between each other and
that's just one of many points that that
you listed I'm a little bit interested
actually I'm a lot interested in this
from you I'm very interested about it
for myself and I'm I'm interested in it
for other people I'm trying to figure
out how to how to disseminate this other
people this idea of staying woke is
different for different people
mm-hm this idea that there are so many
ways up this mountain
some people use meditation some people
use psychedelics some people use
different sorts of communion where they
just go out into nature bathing and
force therapies and all different other
styles of pursuits in this way blue deep
I gazing all they're silly what do we
just explore these do we just explore
these as adults and kids is that an
optimal way to try and get to the stable
criminality
what would your optimal ways I think
also intersectionality and culture
because it's great that we go out and
wake up but what are we waiting up for
and what are we actually doing about it
and if we just get into this because I
see that a lot it as well is like oh
let's go and take more drink more
ayahuasca do more of that
do more of it more of it more of it and
then by the end of but at the end of the
day the person's an [ __ ] to other
people are you woke you know how are you
actually practicing it in society how
are you actually treating people
how are you actually treating the land
what are you actually putting into your
body on a daily basis like you know
you're gonna be doing a manic diet
before going to Peru and then you come
back and you just feed yourself with
fast food fast media not caring not
actually being active in your community
like it's more than that and that's why
I said you know I brought in black life
matters because they actually the stay
woke is there hash it that they use
because they practice community they
waking up people on a daily basis for
what's happening and keeping them
accountable and I think that's why we
need to then do the steps it's not only
stay woke it's literally growing up and
going [ __ ] we did this doesn't feel good
but acknowledging that this is not okay
to continue
and and then beyond that then cleaning
up after us cleaning up the ocean
cleaning up our behavior cleaning up
relationships that are toxic between
genders between different races yeah I
don't want to say racist is such a
problematic word because it doesn't
actually say it's a narrative that we
created that there are the races and yet
at but we're gonna say racism because
that's the framework we created so
that's the cleaning up and then showing
up it's showing up for yourself it's
showing up for your community showing up
for a climate for it for the climate and
for for ones who cannot speak
that's the showing up that's why we do a
march for the planet we do a march for
the Earth because we do you know we're
being The Lorax we speak for the trees
because they can't speak right or in our
language in our human language they have
their own language yeah in in the human
let's call the humanistic language or
the human human language not which is
probably very I believe the human
language is probably not very diverse if
we actually knew how to speak to a tree
we would find out that they speak in a
like the hepta pods in arrival they
speak in three in 360 in a nonlinear way
and we're like trying to actually create
it and they're and they're out of the
that goes in linear thoughts so maybe
that's probably part of our problem what
the [ __ ] that was so dope that was so
awesome
holy cow so I'm sending you a narrative
right now like word by word by word
linearly composing a sentence for you to
get what is that in you to go good then
say back but there's this a tree way of
communicating which is I'm
simultaneously absorbing sunlight while
I'm silent
distributing co2 to all of these other
trees and fungi underneath of the soil
and the systems and I'm feeling all of
this simultaneously and there's there's
ants and and squirrels and all different
types of creatures crawling amongst my
innards and and and there's those humans
walking really slowly and there's humans
walking really fast around
one of them's hanging on my branch now
and yeah
whoa so there's kind of like it would be
like if I'm not only talking to you but
I'm also like completely tapped into the
emotional state of like Ron and I'm
completely tapped into like the state of
other humans inside of these other
sweets in the building and I'm feeling
like the San Francisco like Muni metro
system and like tectonic plates a little
bit and then the weather a little bit
that's like that's a whole new level of
like at a time perception yeah but being
able to filter it because I think that's
enlightenment in a way if being able to
observe all of it and being mindful of
all of it and I think it's also probably
a level of autism as well on the other
spectrum
you can't filter that I think autism is
not the ability is the disability of
actually having filters on everything
and then so how I think enlightenment is
could be the other side of it where you
are able to take it all in and be able
to put filters whenever you need to and
not go mad
it was potentially schizophrenia yeah
Sabrina as well so I I really believe
that that and if you actually look at
the way people who are considered having
these mental issues are looked at today
versus the way that we looked at in
ancient times and for indigenous culture
it's very interesting those were the
seers there's where the ones are able to
see all of that and it's very interest
yeah and and I love that you love it I
mean arrival that movie just blew my
mind very interesting yeah and I think
this is the planet the planet
consciousness is like that talks like
that
Gaia mother earth Pachamama totally
vibes on a 360 yeah everything is like a
neuron communicating together at the
same time yeah that hypothesis is so
important to wrap one's mind around
mm-hmm a big chunk of ass of a central
theme that I that I believe I'm starting
to finally put a little bit of a thumb
on is I think that wrapping one's mind
and heart and perspective out of their
own individual vehicle and into not only
this massive like Gaia collective
consciousness one but even just you know
behind the eyes of one other person or a
timeline-wise it's like you know 26 year
old 52 year old how about we talk on the
scale of thousands or tens of thousands
of years back to when your ancestors
were growing food and that they were
first figuring out tools in language and
agriculture and wheels and fire and
stuff what about long distance in the
future etc but this is the thing is how
do you get one's mind then again up this
stay woke mentality of getting out of
this of just your own mindset and of
just your own timeline yeah well
practice some mindfulness practices
there is 10,000 of them but also I think
we're not allowed to do that as a
culture right now we're very myopic even
in our work what's the next quarter
what's the next year and again if I go
back to indigenous people they actually
do that they look seven generations
backwards and seven generations forward
so they very much think about you know
if I so I'm mostly vegan I still just
eat some eggs don't kill me
and I try to reduce everything even
though I live in a city I shop at
Rainbow grocery San Franciscans know
about it and I bring my own containers
I'm kind of this techno hippie but I
still you know work in the tech industry
I still even though I'm working with a
regenerative group
so I try to think about it without going
mad every day and and that's where
actually my book came out of is this way
of thinking of if you actually sit down
and actually think about every action
that you take that's why the Eightfold
Path is also the right action like the
mindfulness is not oh my god it's
everything the mindfulness is sitting
with that and singing with all that and
just observing and then from that making
the decisions if I pick up right if I'm
hungry
like why am I going to the mac to the to
the McDonald's or meat like is this
something that I really need right now
what's the repercussion to the world on
that what what happens if I make that
decision to actually go with the local
vegetable one of my creating in the
world like think about it on mass if
everybody thought that way we wouldn't
be in the predicament where and we
probably would have been three billion
people thrive a ball and the Star Trek
universe were good but because we're all
in this kind of fight or flight and also
societal you know you know and do put
the honors and us personally but also
societal societies is hard we're not
we're not teaching kids does we're not
supporting them and having a inquisitive
minds we're teaching them to go and
become a worker in the white collar or
blue collar
vertical so they you know by the time
they leave University they don't they
can't actually carry that anymore even
though they we all I believe come into
the world with that kind of perspective
but we're educated out of it so I think
it's really how to get there is work and
open-mindedness and Daniel wall who
wrote the designing regenerative
cultures has this line of sitting with
ambiguity by befriending complexity yeah
and then it's hard and and and also
being there is I think we're not
compassionate to anybody when we're
definitely compassionate to ourselves to
and now
kind of this is kind of this I call it
super positioning of self I do it mostly
what you know I am oh sweet auch about
it when we're having suppositions we're
super positioned here as a human and
then our digital self and we have this
kind of living in two places at the same
time but I think we're also super
positioned as our own mind the idea of
self because self doesn't exist and then
how we worth community help with the
society how society with us so we're in
this kind of little war of expectations
and what I what I know is right and what
my heart is asking for and then all of a
sudden you're overwhelmed and that's
where mindfulness practice comes back
and says and now just observes those
thoughts and breathe because that's what
the planet is about it's just a plan of
brief goes in and out
yeah well that was another good because
the self not only are we dealing with a
self and then a digital self but then
we're dealing with self and we're
dealing with this image well digitally
but then also like collectively like how
do people view me how do I behave in
this game that would the story that we
call earth and with those characters and
then these eight billion characters and
the way they want to like level up their
skill levels and honest what something
that I think is hilarious is like after
you die one of the interesting thought
experience that I've had is just that
you like you have like a big garbage
truck come and dump all of the garbage
that you use throughout your life just
all over you and you just sit there and
be like because that way maybe in your
next you know passage that you get to
realize how ridiculous it was yeah have
you seen the good have you been seeing
the good place oh it's a wonderful
sitcom or just comedy show and it's
about but what happens after you die and
is funny but but the big thing is that
our timeline there hasn't been anybody
in heaven for a long time because even
when we think we're doing something
right like free trade or whatever when
you actually go down the chain you
actually find like horrible
people at the answer actually can't
control your own faith and really do
good because there's too many of us how
do you get a cell phone then yeah
exactly you're like oh my god if I
really want to be good I should live on
the land a hundred percent and not much
else
Jake genius to the highest level like
literally walk with yes the highest
level yeah and that's a really
interesting grow cotton and then make
your own clothes
exactly then just and then you're good
grow apples and yeah I'm corn and just
yeah so we're in that place where but
we're in a wonderful space where
technology can actually keep us Woking
keep us accountable we can use
technology for for you know tracking
where supply chain is like that's where
the promise of the ledger and blockchain
can actually come in to actually show us
oh this is truth this is real so that is
where technology is starting actually I
mean the whole idea of this transparency
even though there's shadows of it like
the the Canadian the Canadian coin
company that just went bust because
their founder was is dead and they can't
actually release a hundred and fifty
million dollars so you've got shadow and
that's shadow work that's that's our
shadow there's always gonna be players
who are gonna be looking at themselves
and always are gonna be players who are
gonna go how do we make this for good so
there's there's both of it and and again
it's who do we feed and right now the
media is feeding the story and not the
amazing people who are doing just
amazing work in the world they need to
be this they need to be the rockstars
the main front and center of the global
narrative right now are the ones that
are doing the regeneration
yeah um okay let's touch on this because
this is really important we haven't
touched on it yet this this creating a
world that works for all beings in the
shortest amount of time we've been
talking about that but this specifically
in terms of our exponential technology
transition especially to moving
potentially further away from biological
beings some people want to move away
from biological beings they want to move
into being digital beings and explore
Digital realms and all this other
universe design and things like that
cool go and do that indigenous people if
you want to not touch that at all and
just live on the earth and not touch
anything else we will absolutely not
come and bother you period so there's a
world that works for everyone I want you
to teach us about how there's tons of
these thriving futures this is not just
limited to singularity done that's only
thing that's it it's all you get to pick
so tell us about that well it's an idea
that I've played with a lot and I'm
writing actually a book based on these
ideas it's a trilogy because one book
couldn't be enough called m-theory and
where I actually look at the I look at
nine possible futures and and there none
of them are 100% dystopian 100% utopia
they're all kind of got they're kind of
good stuff and bad stuff and some of
them look very bad but all of a sudden
you'll find some goodness within them
and and it comes from that kind of
looking at what is the predominant
narratives out there in the past ten
years even its its dystopia and it's
very myopic it's very a hundred percent
dystopia and then there's a little grain
of hopefulness within that and reality's
not like that like reality is actually
much more nuanced so even in the worst
case scenario they're still gonna be
amazing places on the planet that are
going to be thriving for a very long
time worst case scenario if we actually
get our act together we could actually
get more of the earth back to an
equilibrium and also you know not
everybody wants to go into the
singularity ya know not everybody wants
to go to Mars most of us are not gonna
be able to go to Mars cos I don't know
you've seen the Martian and I've read
the Martian kind of sucks that's there
it's like being in a like how how long
before we're actually gonna terraform
Mars and is that the great idea to
actually blow up you know hydrogen bombs
to actually create a reversal of the
atmosphere because that's really how
they're going to do it does that sound
like a great solid or a solution I don't
know and and within that there's this
absolute look the absolute singularity
the absolute bringing back to nature I
think we can't work it with absolutes
because humans don't work in absolute
the concept of an absolute is the
diamond right the diamond cutter and
within it that's the only thing that we
can actually look at as an absolute
everything else is very nuanced so can
we actually agree that some people that
want to be in the singularity we should
have rights for them great but I'm
actually more interested before we give
them all the rights can we have nature
rights first because there is something
very that very with a lot of hubris
Hebraic in the wanting to give AI and
robotics
rights because we birthed them so it's
very much eyes but I'm like wait before
we can actually birth something new
we're literally teenage parents if we're
birthing this new thing we're not adult
enough to actually take care of the
place we came from so I would say we're
13 pregnant 13 13 pregnant yeah we're
totally are that and and it's not a very
positive view of our species it's like
can we be elders and can we actually
have a healthier way of having a
community that births this new entity
this AI and not just a very select few
who are designing it to look like they
are because I have a god complex what
what does an AI look like that whole
people come and build together you know
it's a very different conversation than
the AI that you know Microsoft sent two
years ago and Twitter and became a tween
and 24 hours and was racist like that's
what's gonna happen like right because
that's the people who are actually
designing it they actually don't come
you know they're not actually welcome
they're not most of them even though
there are some amazing groups that are
doing different work like AI for all and
the I Triple E ethical aligned design
that is putting down ethics for the
development of AI na s so there are
amazing people working on thinking
beyond that but if we don't invite
others to this conversation we're gonna
have the singularity that looks pretty
much like the worst dystopian nightmares
that we can think of and it's not gonna
be good so we do need to go wait like
are we thinking about this clearly are
we taking are we really looking at all
the externalities something that we have
never done
for we don't like to look at
externalities I think it's important
that young people hear these
conversations more than anybody yeah
yeah because a lot of the things that
we're we understand I don't want to see
woke too but we're lucky it's because
it's very hard to teach an old dog new
tricks
yeah it's very hard to you need to talk
to for me that doesn't understand these
things yeah so training the faculties of
children to expand their awareness to a
stay woke mentality about Mother Earth
and about this wisdom that's deep inside
of us so a lie happening among us as
well there's also something among us to
wants just to turn into you know a
compliant robots yeah we're very
difficult to control
obviously we're becoming woke and this
is the factors that there's something
out there that does not want us to
achieve yeah damn yeah yeah yeah we we
need to poke and prod at that more
because whatever the forces are is just
figuring out how to turn off that nozzle
a little bit more if we can turn that
one off and turn on the young children
compliance as well to say no that's not
right I don't like that no that's not
right I don't exactly and your shoes
mean that and you're seeing the young
young people under 24 fighting for the
for a positive future fighting for
climate or you know you've got Greg
Grunberg Thornburg waving your finger at
in Davos waving a finger at the UN going
like what the hell guys yeah yeah no
this is not okay you're not like the
house is on fire and I love her clarity
and I like that she's not you know she's
not beating around the bush it's like
hey you told us you're gonna help us
with the future and you're not you're
killing us and and she's literally
speaking truth to power and you've got
the 21 kids that are suing the federal
government going like hey you know
you're you're stealing the future from
us and that is like those that like why
aren't the
the rockstars like why are those not the
number one YouTube influencer you know
this is part of what Venus there's a
reason for all of this there's a reason
why there's suppression of this vital
information to question authority
these are fighting words I'm gonna get
in trouble for saying it so a
matter-of-factly so we're up against a
lot there's something there that kills
us they kill us
yeah we're in the matrix and when we
when you wake up from the matrix it can
never unsee it you always see it and you
always see everybody's still locked into
it and and that's that's really that's
that's sad but also that means that if
you are and it's not a ego woke it's a
humble I am privileged to be awake I am
privileged to practice this I'm
privileged to live in a city that lets
me do my work and speak like that even
though I'm still still have to be
plugged into the matrix in some level
you know as I think that's how do we how
to teach to kids the humility when
they're like on social media when
they're about you know but but you can
actually see the backlash for me live
and the younger ones who don't want to
be in social media they're like wait why
are you guys all even looking at younger
at younger Millennials and like why do
you need to be on online all the time
what do you need to have this fashion
I'm actually stepping away from that so
I think there might be a rebuttal to
that and it is and it is about how do
how do we tell these stories more to
people how do we get these narratives
out more and how do we do it in a way
that talks to both the young but it also
brings in the humility and awe back to
the boardroom back to the fortune 500
they're still human it's it's it's it's
got to come from both ends yeah from the
the highest SES the $3,000 really have
to make a positive effort to grow their
hearts and simultaneously the we have to
respect these
young leading Gen Z yours that are
wanting to leave behind a very positive
long term future at the same time and
figure out how to empower them as
artists and entrepreneurs to scientists
as the next gen thought leaders all at
the same time raise the baseline of
living across the world Maya this is
extremely thought-provoking interesting
can we put let's power around three
questions on the way out okay quick core
driving principle of your life how do
how to build a world that works for all
beings in the shortest amount of time
that's my true north and and it's it's
not a oh I have to do it it's part of
it's part of my life work so it's not
that I stopped because it hasn't been
done or or that I'm gonna give up I just
continue I love it you got me to that's
right I love that no matter what no
matter what that's that's that's a big
that's a big deal and there's a lot of
forces I try and hold back at times
makes the feel that way now you know
you're just teaching about about about
awakening and staying woke and how
difficult it is to look around and see
potentially others that are not and how
to change that is this a simulation it's
a good question
so can I answer it in a little story
mini story do we have time yeah so when
I was four or five I had a dream and in
the dream I could see us expanding out
of the earth and into the edges of the
universe and then when we're at the edge
of the universe I could see where it
actually edged out from and that was the
ending with the tail end of an alligator
and that I could see the whole his whole
or she's whole universe there so we
could be in the dream within a dream so
that was that was kind of my
four-year-old mind actually breathing
into the reality of the matrix of is
this a dream you know am I actually
having this conversation with you really
and don't forget what my name is it's
all an illusion
nothing really incorrect correct yes
someone somewhere someone recently was
asking me about these
these affiliations so do you feel I'm
like I don't even affiliate myself with
my name exactly yeah that's how that's
how I feel yeah and it just makes it
easy to call each other across a room or
whatever it's not the best fit its
narrows down the probabilities it
narrows down the probability it's
exactly that's the calling cuz I can't I
can't grab your your awareness no
awareness or your electron from here and
your atom from here I'm like probability
matrix
Alan this makes most sense yeah um last
question what do you think the most
beautiful thing in the world this planet
yeah it's it's the most beautiful thing
in the world there's nothing like it and
how it it literally holds space for us
to be well you've never been to Zinner
all does it all is a gorgeous planetary
system we're offering condominiums for
three thousand dollars a month right now
your friend will go to 0 all say in
three days four nights jury is see this
is this is nice this is idea is that if
you can do this long this idea of of
what's option B yeah there is no [ __ ]
option yeah this is it this is it yeah
yeah Marv is not an option maybe four
maybe four plenty people awesome is
that's what we're putting our our future
and energy on so yeah I'm putting I'm on
so I know I just thought Doug raschig of
the other the other day and I love him
team human so I'm both on Team human and
team planet and we're also on on team
you know on team technology and we're on
team creating these these these
wonderful ways of flourishing for for
all beings as quickly as possible
and giving people a bunch of thriving
futures whatever they want to pick and
pursue but obviously not harming yeah
collective along the along the pursuit
Maya will have to have you back on for
round two this has been slow so
beautifully enlightening
thank you you are amazing we love you
thank you lovely we love you we love
thank you do everything to help thank
you thank you thank you thank you thank
you ruin thanks everyone for tuning in
we greatly appreciate you we'd love to
hear your thoughts below on these
thriving futures on building a community
conversation around this and go and talk
to other people about it your family
your friends your co-workers all these
different people around you talk to them
about this regenerative earth practice
about how to stay woke
for long periods of time and help other
people with it as well with awakening
much love to Ron from producing and
directing we love you so much and to
everyone as well support the artists and
entrepreneurs and scientists in your
local communities that you believe and
go and support them support people like
Maya support people like simulation
Maya's links are below our links are
below as well get supporting everyone
and go and build the future manifest
your destiny into the world take this
limited amount of time that we have on
the planet and go and thrive we love you
so much and we will see you soon peace
[Applause]
that was awesome thank you
[Music]
you
[Music]